many of you over the last 24 48 Hours
wrote to me about some very particular
statements made by former 60 Minutes
journalist Lara Logan that are quite
frankly utterly deranged now I don't
know how many in the audience know the
trajectory of Lara Logan but Lara Logan
was at one point sort of a respectable
journalist and she has increasingly gone
down the conspiracy Rabbit Hole over the
last year we've talked about her
anti-semitic conspiracy theories
anti-vaccine conspiracy theories covid
medical disinformation just a sort of
all of the above type thing I don't know
whether this is a character she's
playing or whether she really is off the
rails but I am going to show you a
couple of clips of what happens when you
really are infected by proverbial brain
worms Lara Logan was interviewed by
Newsmax two days ago
and she claims to have spoken to a man
who infiltrated the global cabal at the
U.N even she seems confused by what
she's claiming it is bit very scary
stuff I would get the kids out of the
room for this one but you know what it's
even bigger than that because um I you
know I I spoke to a man who was actually
holding the documents in his hand he
told me about it right he said he was uh
he infiltrated the global uh cabal at
the UN level right and one of the things
that he was able to
um to to tell me about from his own
personal experience what he witnessed
himself was these documents that showed
that the plan there is a plan and this
was several years ago right the plan was
to infiltrate a hundred million illegal
immigrants and at that point they were
already at 40 million now think about
how insane this is
infiltrate 100 million undocumented
immigrants to the United States a third
of the U.S population I mean it does no
matter what state you live in this
doesn't even pass the sniff test just
think about what that would mean in
terms of our daily lives it it's not
even remotely plausible and these people
would dilute what they called the pool
of Patriots those with their words right
yeah now that's that's great replacement
stuff we we've talked about that for a
while that's the idea of a concerted uh
plan by democrats to replace white
people with non-white people in order to
control this that and this is Tucker
Carlson's stuff but just with slightly
less eloquent language
and they would not be taught that
America is a great country and trained
to sing the national anthem with pride
and they wouldn't be trained to sing the
national anthem think about that
language
we train people to sing the national
anthem with pride
so sounds pretty authoritarian fascistic
someone and so on they would be told all
the negative things that were told about
the U.S city that our own children are
told and and what would be the effect of
diluting the pool of Patriots well it
would be to break down this sense of
pride in being American and what it
means to be American yeah really really
scary stuff and to think that just I
don't know what was it a decade ago she
really was a pretty respectable
journalist doing pretty respectable
journalism she also you know it's it's
not just anti-science it's not just
conspiracies but it's also this
pseudo-religious stuff where she's not
necessarily
saying that these are her Christian
beliefs but she's talking about Satan as
if Satan is a sort of conscious actor
with agency listen to this Bonkers stuff
it's right out of it's right out of the
Playbook the right out of the Socialist
Playbook you divide and conquer you
don't tell them your intent you get
people to come in you got your useful
idiots those of us who are paying for
these people to have all these luxuries
and they lie about it yeah how's it end
well okay
it's badly for some
um okay so on a serious note
um you know people of all faiths have
said to me that this is a spiritual
battle I am a fern and solid and
immovable believer in God now understand
that what what do you mean you're saying
the Muslims came to you and that this is
a spiritual battle against
immigrants who are mostly religious also
the Jews came to you the Buddhists
everybody's coming to you saying Lara
these are really battles of Faith
against the immigrants what the hell are
you talking about and I believe that God
wins I believe that good is greater than
evil and I believe that the Fallen Angel
otherwise known as Satan doesn't get to
Prevail in this world so um if you
follow the Bible or if you follow the
Quran or you follow the Book of Mormon
you know people talk in various
different ways about the end times and
if you fight for God the end times guys
the end times God will fight for you but
people Humanity final thought though I
have to I have to ask you this because
my audience is very God-fearing God
loving Etc final thought I only a couple
of seconds please
um this is God okay with a closed border
it's much bigger than that God believes
that in in sovereignty and national
identity and the sanctity of family and
all the things that we've lived with
from the beginning God also has chosen
Ford over Chevy he's really weighing in
on every issue we have time and he knows
that the open border is Satan's way of
taking control of the world through all
of these uh people who are his sujas and
his and his servants and they may think
that they're going to become Gods that's
what they tell us you all know a Harari
and and all the rest of them at the
world economic Forum you know the ones
who want us eating insects cockroaches
and that while they dine uh on the blood
of children those are the people right I
love how Eric balling is like right
because you know the ones that want us
eating the insects and the Cockroaches
and dining on the blood of children
right right who's sicker the person
saying this stuff the host taking it
seriously or the audience members who
believe it I don't have the answer but
they're all pretty sick in my book
I want to tell you about something I use
every day because it simplifies my life
I don't have hours to mathematically
plan every meal or take multiple
different supplements and vitamins to
make sure I'm getting exactly what I
want to get every single day and the
solution is our sponsor athletic greens
product ag1 I've been taking ag-1 for
over a year it's just great it's just
one small scoop of ag1 in the morning I
get 75 vitamins minerals probiotic all
from whole food sources it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's no
extraneous stuff making wild claims I
drink it straight with water because I
like the taste you can put it in a
smoothie or juice or a shake it's just
simple ag1 is a sustainable routine
because it's just one scoop in the
morning takes one minute once a day I
know I'm covered in getting what I want
I can really be sure that I am properly
nourishing my body with the things I'm
trying to get that's the most important
part athletic greens knows I'm a vitamin
D guy I've talked about in the winter I
take vitamin D to make up for the lack
of sun exposure I take that every day as
well I've mentioned it on the show and
so athletic greens is giving you a free
year of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first purchase when you
go to athleticgreens.com Pacman the link
is down below